We like to play a quick round of?
Drewth or Dare!
Mm-hmm.
(audience cheers)
(air whooshes)
Okay, we have Liz Wessel here.
Hi Liz.
Is that the correct
pronunciation?
Hi, got it!
Yes!
Perfect, yes!
So I have a Drewth for you both.
Okay.
Oh.
If you were to swap bodies for one day,
what is the very first thing you would do
when you woke up in the other's body?
Oh, oh.
Oh.
I would be like, "Whoa."
I know.
That's my honest answer (laughs).
Leave it alone.
(Drew laughs)
(Ross laughs)
What would you do?
What, oh, nothing.
Nothing like that.
I can't help it, if you woke up,
all of a sudden as a man
that would be the first thing I would think to marvel at.
Where your brain goes is so funny.
Right to the potty.
Yeah, right?
Well, gosh, I wish I did wake up in your body, Ross
because here's what would really happen.
Yeah.
(Ross chuckles)
I would be to disciplined
'cause sometimes I am not really disciplined.
And you are really disciplined
with your food and your diet and your wellness.
Oh, you wouldn't eat a whole bowl of mac and cheese?
(Drew chuckles)
Which is what she tries to get me to do
around here all the time.
I know, no!
You wouldn't do that?
I would be excited that you have strong willpower.
Yeah, thank you.
Well, it's new, it's new.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
If I woke up as Drew Barrymore,
I mean, I would wanna green light
a new Charlie's Angel movie
and cast Ross Matthews as Bosley,
but I wouldn't do that, I wouldn't.
(audience cheers)
I would do whatever I could to set you up for the next day
'until have a day off with your daughters.
That's what I would do.
'Cause I know that's what my friend, Drew,
loves more than anything in the world.
I know, God, Ross, what is wrong with me?
Well...
(Drew chuckles)
All right, all right, let me, God!
It makes you feel better, I would take a peek.
I would just 'cause.
(audience laughs)
Would you?
'Cause I'd never
seen it, really before.
(Ross laughs)
(Drew laughs)
Liz, aren't, you glad you asked?
I love it, thank you so much.
Great question.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪